voilà en fait un petit ardi vie urbaine
s'est amusé comme le bouge pas
vous pensez à quoi la question que je me
posais bonnes réponses
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
la dernière chose j'enlève mon caleçon
donc quand tu entends même violine et le
matin qu'on vit dans la glace me dit
quoi j'étais mieux hier arrêtez de
croire ça mais d'ici là j'aurai pression
mais pas qu'elles sont
vous changez avec moi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
si j'avais une baguette magique moi je
me trouve bien il a un physique aussi
pour jouer dans les dents les des plots
ouais bon bien physique pour l'épreuve
mais c'est ça que je trouve qu'il a
vraiment serge alors donnons millar est
ce que tu peux faire un gros plan de
faire un péplum meiway à gladstone aux
genoux et revient de loin
le deuxième carrière
c'est vrai tu fais le même plan tu mets
la compagnie créole par dessus tu vas
voir les purs d'avancé - là bien fait ça
dans mes séries vous ressemblez à
charlton heston
ça y est on a trouvé on a trouvé la fin
d'existence
alors quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre genre t'es nul
ouais on s'est forgé qui vous le dit ça
l'est encore plus ah ouais quand c'est
votre femme c'est moins grave voulait
dire qu'est ce que les fameux cherchait
toujours à part le moment j'en devais me
ferais un caleçon
ah non c'est pas il faudrait leur
demander
préféré à jerry hall à la moelle me
regarderait comme ça c'est dit on chez
moore ou encore des mois pour l'euro à
la sortie ou tués james allison
seul song dit j'aime beaucoup derrière
l'histoire balle à l'épaule
c'est fou bon alors est ce que vous êtes
déjà senti le maître du monde n'ont pas
encore n'ont pas encore pas encore
j'espère ça viendra la suite place way
qui est de bon goût là pour voir du
gratin il ya un gars si sampras qu'avec
la cité numéro un c'est numéro un
oui parce qu'ils ont changé de placement
et quatre buts et des gens mais si je
suis un petit peu le sport c'est comment
il est parfaitement tennis lui je suis
santé j'adore ça tous les jours soit
cédric et même bien jusqu'à maintenant
les gars on va diffuser par endesa
alors si c'était à refaire dans votre
vie qu'est ce que vous feriez pas pareil
qu'est ce que je ferais tu appareils
pour les français comment on dit how do
you say party
six douilles et super le mans et titi
gâteau
donc si c'était à refaire vous si
c'était à refaire mais j'adore ma vie
avant lui changera rien non je n'ai pas
envie de noms je suis bien comme je suis
moins bon ces agents sera encore un
petit plan joué à philippe tesson qui
attend je me fais engueuler on se fait
un petit plan ben-hur charlton heston
sur pioline et ont passé la suite
c'est de réguler ce cabinet
voilà on peut rallumer les lumières